if a doctor spent 26 hours a day reading
that's how long it take for him to keep
up with how much informations come in on
terms of best practices and even the
best practices when do people do the
research it takes them about 17 plus
years before even comes to a best
practice at the hospital our clinicians
our doctors and nurses and pharmacists
take all this medical research and best
practices and condense it down to maybe
a seven or eight page actual order set
our checklist for the doctor to use at
the bedside with order sets it allows us
to basically take that shorten that
17-year gift lifecycle down to roughly
about three months because we do with pH
I data personal health information you
have to take it very seriously and when
it comes to data residency encryption at
rest all the stuff there and all built
in-house as we grew it became way more
work and a lot of work a lot of ities
required to actually support our own
servers our infrastructure the solutions
we're using with IBM are specifically
infrastructure as a service and platform
as a service working with IBM has been
great they're always available to us and
they're always listening to us and what
we need and getting the right people to
help us solve our problems of day to day
basis all those server issues that we
known deal with Maya's perspective has
been all covered by IBM even with the
comfort of platform the service you know
even running our own kubernetes cluster
we thought about that for even a bit but
you know not to have to worry about
where that server instructor is up has
allowed our DevOps team to really just
focus on building tools for the
developers and operations to really
drive quicker turnaround times for our
applications to our clients it's been a
great choice from my perspective I'm
working with IBM we'll continue doing
that
you